The answer is it requires me to completely trust Coleen.
Coleen knows that I'm giving a message to her, and she can open that message
and know that it goes to Alice.
It doesn't require the first one.
If Bob see me talking with Coleen, presumably that's not a problem.
It doesn't require the second if Bob sees Coleen talking with Alice.
That's also not a problem.
If Bob sees both of those and sees them in quick succession,
especially if he sees the envelopes being handed on,
then he's got a good reason to suspect that I'm talking with Alice.
So we need both of these properties.
We need to know that Coleen can be trusted,
and we need to know that Bob can't see both of these transactions.
Those are pretty high security assumptions.
We don't want to have to trust Coleen completely,
and we don't want to rely on the fact that Bob can't see these two conversations.
The way to make it more secure is to add a third person--
let's say we know Edgar as well.
Now instead of giving the message directly to Coleen,
what I'm going to do is take the envelope for Coleen,
put that inside an envelope for Edgar. We need to fold things a little to make them fit.
Now I'm going to seal this envelope with a very secure seal
that only Edgar can open.
Now I'll give this to envelope to Edgar.
Edgar will open it, see that it has an message for Coleen.
Edgar will give the message to Coleen.
Coleen will open that, see that it has a message for Alice, give the message to Alice.
Alice will open the message
and see that she shouldn't eat the onion.
This has more protection. Now Coleen doesn't know that I'm communicating with Alice.
Because the message is going like this:
It's going first to Edgar, then to Coleen, then to Alice.
Neither Edgar, nor Coleen knows that I'm communicating with Alice.
Edgar knows that I'm sending a message through him that goes to Coleen.
Coleen knows that she's receiving a message from Edgar, and it's going to Alice.
Neither one knows both endpoints.
If we add enough hops, this can start to be quite secure.
This is actually called onion routing.
That's why the message is to not eat the onion.
The name comes from the idea that an onion has all these layers.
As you peel off the layers, you get deeper into the onion.
Doing this with envelopes would be pretty painful.
We want to do this with math. How do we do this with cryptography.